Happiness, we all crave the feeling of contentment and satisfaction
But not everyone actually achieves it
for many individuals the presence of a great family life and a flourishing career is
often not enough a
Smart individual can have all these things and more but still feel a sense of loneliness and sadness
Here are six reasons why smart people sometimes struggle to find happiness.
number one
intelligent people
overanalyze
It's common for an individual of high intelligence to overthink and analyze every aspect of their life
While this analytical nature can be a great asset
Constantly analyzing everything in your life only leads to frustration and exhaustion
Your knowledge and life experiences have taught you to have a critical eye
This is a burden that many people don't carry simply because they don't think on this level
Plus there are the timeless dilemmas and philosophical issues that seem to have no solution
The more you try to figure it all out the less satisfied you become in your quest for understanding in this case the saying
"Ignorance is bliss" is true. Number two
intelligent people have high standards
Smart individuals like to hold everything in their life to high standards and the failure to reach these standards
Ultimately leads to disappointment
be it your career, your relationships or even the talent and skill level that you bring to your daily activities
if your expectations are unrealistic
Prepare to be disappointed and the greater and more unrealistic the expectations
The greater the letdown when these hopes aren't met number three
Intelligent people are extremely self-critical
Unhappiness four highly intelligent people also stems from their deep thinking nature
When you compare yourself to those high standards
You'll blame your failures on your own shortcomings
This self critical nature directly combats your happiness and then fault-finding becomes your new normal
Intelligent people often think back to events of the past into situations in which they behaved poorly or made the wrong choice
You may not realize it but this constant regret over past decisions is robbing you of happiness every day
But those who are able to forgive themselves and work beyond these issues are on the path to happiness
number four
Intelligent people are overly ambitious
It's very difficult for a person of high intelligence to be satisfied with what they already have
Your complex mind causes you to constantly seek something bigger and better, a greater purpose if you will
This drive to achieve can make you miss the simple things in everyday life that bring others a great deal of satisfaction
Your mind craves intellectual stimulation and you aren't satisfied until you find it. Then you need more of it
For this mindset the saying "stop and smell the roses" can be helpful
number five
Intelligent people are often misunderstood
We all want to be understood and accepted for who we are
It's great to share meaningful conversations with a like-minded person and to find someone who shares your own worldviews and philosophies
This can be quite difficult to find for a person of high intelligence
When you feel like no one can connect with you on your level you feel alone and misunderstood
It's been proven that people with high levels of intelligence don't need to socialize as much as others
But the need for human interaction is still there
When you have a high intelligence
You just prefer to talk about meaningful and fascinating things
Rather than trivial subjects such as food or weather or other people number six
intelligent people often develop psychological issues
numerous studies have shown links between psychiatric problems and high intelligence
Anxiety and bipolar disorder are among the most common
It's not certain whether these disorders come from having a brilliant mind or not. But the prevalence of the connections cannot be ignored
Even in the absence of severe mental disorders if you have exceptionally high intelligence
Chances are you may struggle with depression because of the reasons mentioned above
When you constantly think on these things you may also find yourself reflecting on life and death and the purpose of existence
Topics that are often accompanied by feelings of sadness. in the end you hold the key to your own happiness
Sure, the circumstances around you play a big part, but that doesn't mean they determine your happiness
Sometimes you have to adjust your perspective and priorities to really find this happiness
What are your thoughts about this? How do you find happiness in your struggles? Let us know in the comments
also, we'd love to thank our sponsor betterhelp, an
Affordable online counseling platform by real psychologists. if you are interested in learning more. It's in the video description below